ladies and gentlemen Bryan Callen is
playing grab-ass in Montreal so I found
a guy he doesn't have a lot going on he
doesn't have a huge fight on Saturday
happened to be in town he's a little
better in Bryan town it just a pathway
better looking better looking little
blue topper huge your dick mm yeah
counts boxing might be better if you ask
you it's been will kick definitely
better but I ladies and gentlemen the
one the only Donald Cerrone in the house
yes sir what's up brother looking good
get your crew here you guys got looks
like sons of anarchy Mongol [ __ ] up in
there how come I don't get one man all
these around man if you don't have a
motorcycle Ali I don't know why you
drive like my life I don't want to die
that's also another valid point it's
gonna bring out everything you have to
be on your P's and Q's oh you're sure
you're splitting lanes then that's it
that's the thing we can't do anywhere
else but here in LA apparently you can
just Lions don't matter you just gonna
do on this earth and you're all you're
having fun you're an Albuquerque open
roads and there's all these Mexicans and
white people good times and this is I'm
a hashtag no racism you got a lot of
Asian we have a lot of Asians over run
you over come on [ __ ] cannot drive
the three real hair chains they cannot
drive yes it was wild we're on our way
to rob this morning and skips in with us
he has my sling shot so it's like a
motorcycle with three wheels oh yeah
those are fun well it was nighttime
traffic they're not fun so we were just
like sitting there sitting there sitting
- finally you're like [ __ ] you got
dad just we're out of here then we
started skipping the lanes everybody
else because he's just chilling because
I'll see those big-ass
brood on those things he left at seven
o'clock this morning we didn't get it it
took us two hours to go like 20 miles
you're in Orange County
we're in Anaheim dr. what that's Lacey
Orange County you what time did you try
coming down the other 7 a.m.
who told you do that yeah bro you need
hit up those sunny boys get a helicopter
some shopping yeah do something you're
Donald Cerrone yeah I could have made
some calls got you at least a police
escort ass Amish land without me
you better call Dana with that foreign
mill get your uber chopper some [ __ ] you
fighting Saturday then Katie sit in
traffic that's the worst time OC
to LA traffic rush hour for dead
about it it was insane that was gonna
burn out all I gonna cut stop no Scott
go so your boys all you guys have
motorcycles in one home boys on the
three-wheeler yeah Brandon gifts in our
strike oh I love that yeah he spends the
best man yeah he's actually still over
at Robert Hill Holden pass for him so
really yeah rather the whole jimin's
base is pretty cool is Rob any good on
the pads oh I'm talking about Rob
formerly Sonny also known as uh Mac rack
yeah he are you seen a blue belt he said
guys like I feel like I got a Hollywood
Blue Gum Hollywood's oh no he's like I
feel about it but I said I bet some
black belt Hollywood black belt oh
that's cool man
I mean he came down stayed the ranch for
you know couple months became good
friends cool he's hilarious and his wife
Kaitlyn is unbelievably funny show I
guess she makes I don't know if you eat
this I feel like you're too manly for
this and I'm gonna show how I'm ten
percent gay but I mean her flying to Las
Vegas talked about how she makes the
meanest avocado toast in the world I
don't know if you haven't got a toast
well it does sound like something table
toast with avocado on a yeah basically
right little salt like vinegar and I
mean I'd you [ __ ] with that I'd give it
I wouldn't that wouldn't be that might
make which is made all right all right I
don't know if you I love avocado I'm I'm
more of a avocado on the spoon kind of
guy ask her about it after she onset
they bring her this out because they're
making a burrito for breakfast we have
wrists so you got there and they're all
bagged up when her life hmm she said I
also make bags have a bag Mexican
sweatshop in the back yeah she is she's
so good at making that toast on set I
know Sonny they bring her the
ingredients and she makes it for the
staff every day Jose see this [ __ ] is
you need to go up there and ask her tell
her I need an avocado toast tell her be
okay Brennan said you make the best I've
become best was uh so raza today's build
this brand new house they have a tree
fort in the back and Rob was telling us
that he built the tree for and I was
like I mean it's it's badass t44 yeah I
for his kids okay but their kids doing a
[ __ ] yeah and the tree fort has like
concrete barriers sub floor railing
doors windows and I was like you well I
didn't actually do the windows the doors
I need a railing oh just violently like
you paid for the wood so you build your
kitty condos backyard in a tree it's
literally O'Connor I guess the kid wants
a penthouse fingerprint recognition
injury yeah it's polluted you're like oh
wow okay you got a ops you have a a busy
week typical fight week for you
yeah always always are always big
interviews all that for cities we should
all have to I saw you don't have to do
the open workouts does that offend you I
don't know oh hell no you don't want to
do it yeah I don't carry it's not like
anyone's doping workouts is like oh well
I'm glad balls up in hitting I know he
was before god I was looking how
fatigued and out of shape looks get the
hell outta here
it's just that well yeah 170 so nice
though so great or ten pounds over eaten
wherever we want we had uh you don't
look wait how do we last night had Joe's
Crab Shack Joe's you hold up you came to
LA in at Joe's Crab Shack who's across
street in the hotel okay I thought that
yeah I've got a five minute I thought
Lavar Johnson when Cain fought Lesnar on
the same card stay motel there's a Joe's
Crab Shack Outback Steakhouse yeah
alright day you know movie goes Crab
Shack
what Brandon was already over there so
he's went there it's easy I got take
some good restaurants man also can't
fatten you up too much man soon
afterwards over towards there you know
chill for a little bit after I don't
know what am i doing yet I'm not sure
decided Obama I'm a day-to-day kind of
guy you're a day-to-day took type of
dude wherever the wind blows were going
I was going to ask you I've been saying
for a while now how everyone's talking
about how and I love your perspective on
John Jones and I know you guys love each
other but how everyone saying oh he's
never he's never been so disciplined
he's trained so hard and I seem like
dressing different and shaved and all
this stuff to me I don't like that like
you so if somewhat if let's say Rob's
ODU or my agent was like yo man song
cowboy he's no longer jet skiing yeah
not on his motorcycle he's in the
three-piece suit and he's driving a
Royals Royce yeah I don't know Wyatt but
yeah man he's not having any fun he's
going to bed at 10:00 10:00 p.m. he's
eating all his veggies no Budweiser he's
that he's just stray old man he watches
Golden Girls at night that's what he's
doing now
I'd like oh he's got to get [ __ ] up
that's not a cowboy I don't I don't know
that cowboy yeah you know I'm saying so
high on what everyone tells me as I go
oh I love oh that's good or bad you're
talking Rogen this morning is dude I
heard John is looking like a beast oh my
god help if I like that I like train
hard
who the [ __ ] vine oh man I don't know I
mean we train the same gym but you know
how there's different different you do
your own thing different yeah well and
I'm totally different than everybody so
I got the ranch we train there and we're
too busy [ __ ] off most the time so
how do you do it so there's there's
Aussie Jackson's
right and then you have the ranch yeah
and then when you do sparring you go to
Jackson's most everyone come to either
or mostly they come up to me really yeah
so you're basically I mean you're part
of Jackson's basically it's it's your
own like super team up there yeah
exactly super team BMF ranch we don't
raise cattle we're a bad [ __ ]
that's dope man that's so dope so then
you'll just picture so who sets your
schedules there in Cowboys schedule Don
Calogero really I mean Gibson and Gregg
they all collaborate we make like we
kind of try it we try and do like two or
three days because any more than that I
can't stick with but we try and like
schedule schedule we do yeah cuz some
days just wake them but I want to hop
the lake yeah jet ski or [ __ ] jump
off a building I'm trying to get Joe
showing sky dive with me he's deathly
afraid of heights I would never do that
either
why buzz I go through this County this
difference you mean you I go pros and
cons pros I have to get time to lamb
bill it's a fun time man you experience
I'm cool Khan died i yeah Wow Whitley I
many of you know that I've been
skydiving I will how many not many you
don't know many we know me and I'm still
alive
yeah you're crazy dude you never you
never hear me like oh man
he went skydiving and died to change as
pudgy only here that they're not like
always drive got another one this is but
you know so do you jump out by yourself
with y'all
no so that I dude on your back [ __ ] no
how am I gonna how could I oh my girl or
not you know I couldn't put a picture on
the fridge than their dude behind my
girl oh so fun yeah hey know so I went
to my very first jumper solo went to all
the classes and everything yeah there's
no way I was like when you jump so low
you've never done it before
yeah just the only way I dress you gotta
like go do these courses and yeah I
heard if you're over 225 pounds though
you have to jump so low so like my big
ass I must have big Gary on my back with
a 500-page I can't do it so I heard that
my weight like it's trouble like the
parachutes aren't built for big dudes
right did you ever take that
consideration
I'm also I'm not a big dude I'm like
right in the middle I just but would it
go when you jump and you're not so low
usually with it like a group yes
well so I made Greg Jackson Jaffar emo
wrestling coach and Brandon Gibson all
jump solo also I made him go take the
course and jump and brand new staff
ascator high so he did it and Greg was
right there with me let's call it let's
roll into this is the best time ever
Greg wants to do it again Brandon said
he's done it
checkmark will never do it again that's
for and me I love every second I'll do
it today
you love it love it this is a craziest
feeling man craziest feeling I don't
like lying the canopy that's like the
most boring part to me when you're
cruising I just like [ __ ] floating
boring but you can pull it do I go
tricks and spins and [ __ ] but the free
phones where it's at man
[ __ ] bats versus men in anything your
mind so of course I'm watching Point
Break and still standard and I'm like I
have to do this but what you can't do
what they have in the movie for a Gustad
like yeah bro go ahead none of that how
it's not a on you can do is up yeah
that's about a chaos is the right word
yeah well we get dude
pour your corn is Joe's Crab Shack like
that's not happening at a [ __ ] chance
ever have you do you know a guy named
Andy stump now I'm almost scared to
introduce you to because Andy was a
former Navy SEAL
now he's duh like the leading
and far as far as those squirrel suits
the jumpsuit yes he's I need 200 GS in
the world before you can get into one of
those he's like one of the best in the
world have you ever seen the [ __ ] he
does the guys almost touched Lisa sure
they go by to match him he has I think
at the time someone might have beat it
but he was the guy who's in that red
bull suit jump off like basically from
the moon oh yeah he's at dude he's been
on here and you know the people don't
ever have the rocket he was in they just
left that bullet is still up there
yeah space you know this guy's [ __ ]
like you know I just don't watch our
trash a couple hundred million dollars
they just say we're going to put you in
his rocket you jump out and throw a
little sticker on it and call it a day
Red Bull covers that I assume but he was
saying how like he does all these crazy
jumps in the suits are expensive his
[ __ ] and he has to get used to the suit
and does all these jumps but he was
saying when he gets there like people
with barely in the experience are there
and he will look at people like you know
he's gonna die right now that's me like
he literally looks really like you know
like it's just in a matter of time I
assume how many times you can jump
because like I've jumped like whatever
100 times I did you know die yeah and
that's gonna be me you love that [ __ ] he
would look at me and say here but I'm
the guy that I did you're too smart for
that oh no I have someone said Kelly
well here's the thing with jump as I
never said there's no like jumped police
there's that someone going to give you a
ticket for putting this glove on so all
I do is find some wild enough to give me
their squirrel suit and I'm out of here
he said you can buy I think you buy one
off like eBay or some [ __ ] like that
super sketchy a used one uh only three
flies on this one here yeah yeah but he
said the thing is like his suits like is
the little it makes a difference so like
you do right when you should or whatever
you know like specially when he has to
warm up when you pull your ripcord right
whatever hat actually made with your
right hand you have to counteract with
your left hand so when you go to pull
your chute you need to bring your right
hand in front your hand look at y'all
timber grab your chute and pull because
one hand here put you into like a spin
right like so any little motion I can
only imagine wearing a canopy doing it
you just got spun out of control or just
be crazy all in here we're talking about
it and he goes yeah bring it up we
brought on YouTube and he was like look
at this guy
and we're watching daggers goes
eople he's like laughs and I'm like
what's wrong with you
he's just a crazy [ __ ] he's awesome but
he's crazy I'm scared to introduce you
too because I feel like you two would
come up with some sort of that should be
a reality show yeah you two trying to
just not die not dying there you go
I got a lot of [ __ ] I got a lot of [ __ ]
to do left in life so I don't I'm not
gonna die well that's why I don't want
to induce you to Andy cause any like oh
how about this cowboy I feel like this
you might be more crazy than he is and
I'm saying wait till you have a kid wait
to Union grab a [ __ ] kid your kids
going to come out with horns an Evel
Knievel [ __ ] cape yeah ready to go
and you're gonna put you through pure
hell I am be alright I'm ready MA be
ready I'm ready I'll be ready
I love Italy some worry about a kid
right now just because I mean doesn't
like stop my life all my friends have
kids like that much do you want to do
this I got I got the kid I definitely I
doing this look depends well you know
I'm still doing my thing but it depends
on you gotta have a beast of a girl at
home beat a girl it's just we'll hold
the fort on an old hair I think would
you say one of the old hair is that one
was uh lady from another country that
come and raise your kid and I'll be like
hey let me talk about that manly yeah
Cannell overcome the nannies uh you know
and teach another language raised it
ones like five or six what I can like to
start winning and sports then calming on
this look okay wasn't I'll talk my girl
about that
ever since i watch Game of Thrones I
become different man like I'm too
[ __ ] nice man you watch Game of
Thrones and it's the woman's role in the
men's role it's so much different man so
that's that's some Game of Thrones
mentality like I feel like if you had a
kid it should it be Spartan you're in
the [ __ ] 300 your kids like what is
the eight male I get ready down get the
[ __ ] out it's go kill a [ __ ] werewolf
or whatever and it's not gonna stop your
life roaming the werewolves are alive
yeah I just dude it's not going to stop
your life it's just gonna like you're
not gonna be able to just dip out yeah I
get that's not problem I'm a dip out
kind of guy till then no like you're
gonna be 40 dipping out and [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna be like the old guide to bar
and was like what's the creepy old guy
doing everything he's bluffing I just
chant
[ __ ] just and whether leather leather
leather just hot dog skin it sucks down
to your boots uh-huh
just oh my god I know you might not know
family I know only fat wallet in the
back just a purple neck up in the Sun so
and why would I be lonely as everyone's
eyes though they say is lonely at the
top it's not now when you bring everyone
to the table with you it's not lonely
but you're not lonely but the difference
is is you're not a lonely guy people
love to be around you so I'm like I'll
be at night you're getting my other 80
year old friends that are still running
with me yeah psych who's brain trauma
kicks in first memory so your group of
friends your wizard [ __ ] animal you
guys are savages right look like who's
gonna remember who before the brain
trauma kicks in that's your bad well the
best part is we could meet each other
again like like oh [ __ ] bro but you ride
Moses you know we're in the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] right on Bardo and over over
like 50 first dates of them's in the
army no problem it might be a good life
but I can't do actually oh man
yeah I miss I miss Collins shame had to
take over a show now poor guy told
county [ __ ] up man he's in you know
this summer's been a beast for both ask
Ellen why so affected like do four shows
and save them do stuff like that and I'm
here he's there and then we told me
you're in town I told count said man you
messed up table coming on take your spot
take your spot take a spot and we've had
a couple of monsters Tony Hinchcliffe
sat in people loved him now people are
gonna love you
good good have you been keep up with
your podcasts now of course not of
course not cowboy why would you while
you're busy knocking out the best guys
in the world that's it I love it
speaking of which this fight will be so
fun man this is I don't even know why I
got to keep promoting this fight if you
aren't interested in watching me to
[ __ ] legends who want to fight each
other fight it's the best it's what is
Haq I mean this card is [ __ ] Bella
Bell right it is
I mean you cuz you guys are supposed to
fight before right and then he didn't
have a [ __ ] together right let's watch
camp eyes and you know word got out it's
nothing
I mean came out like a robbie lawler
turned down the fight yeah but really he
just didn't his camp was in America
which is you know you were Robbie no one
scared to fight any now at this level so
I just don't be as camp together and
then now finally you guys are making it
happen
yes supposed to have been 213 and I got
AIDS and had to get a blood rampage I'm
good now go down as it goes away like
that
he goes away like this which my blood
what was up with that man so I burned my
knee on a motorcycle you know child
finishes then we work out the next day I
wake up my knee hurts oh my god am i
nice [ __ ] sore like I just figure I
tweaked or something so a minor the next
day just swole up and red and I was like
couldn't even move as I golf [ __ ] I
better go to the hospital I go in and
they had mersa and they're like hey man
this is [ __ ] you waited too long it's
now in your blood so you're staying with
us just as dangerous as soon as they
admitted me and put the IV in you saw to
stepped in I came in you can't fight you
you're not a lot of how IVs hey you
Sallah yeah [ __ ] kick rocks man so
he's on IV yeah I couldn't fight if I
wanted you so then Dana just posted on
to the next it's almost better than it I
mean sure I would have self all last
weekend or whenever we're sure but it's
almost better this is also the dick man
like the blood it like floored me [ __ ]
me up well mersa if you guys know that
Murph is like what's its staff I make it
was [ __ ] able super holy Oh like it's
like it's like it's like it's the stuff
that eight temperament recipes yeah yeah
I'm horrible [ __ ] within your
bloodstream it's super deadly super good
yeah the worst thing I've ever like you
need to be on antibiotic through IV that
right now like so it's so 10 days I do
that and it comes like out of nowhere
like my boy Joe Klopfenstein he was
playing for the Rams and he got a scrape
on his knee got tackled and he's like
damn I mean it feels hot hot yeah then
you tell me like how something feels
wrong with my knee he kept playing all
the sweat whatever from the pad
goes home that night you wakes up in a
cold sweat and his [ __ ] knees blew up
and had the same thing mersa rush to the
emergency room and they're like dude you
if you would have waited any longer
probably dead that's crazy I'm seriously
where is our side track when my knee was
hurting because we just got a new plasma
cutter and we're in the garage [ __ ]
metal a [ __ ] welding [ __ ] out so
that's what I got sidetracked by do that
figure out about the knee but I came out
and like kneel down I kept telling
everybody [ __ ] why New York it's like I
can barely kneel on it and then the old
hot knee so how does I go to eat all day
like a day what's of it yeah I guess our
line the motorcycle I called the
insurance for UFC because I pay for my
emergency ax and they caught and then
assuming that suit open whatever right
away especially when something like that
and so they called me like what the [ __ ]
and Dana first of course says of course
you heard on a [ __ ] motorcycle or
wakeboard or some dumb [ __ ] yeah and I
was like man really it wasn't even my
fault someone tipped the motorcycle over
I helped him pick it up and it [ __ ]
burn my knee that's really what happened
really what happened really you ever
coming back from the lake I was in a
pair of board shorts and at the gas
station motorcycle the kickstand was
only down it fell over so I helped him
pick the bike up to it got me God would
made up a way crazier story I know I
wish I wish I could have but those those
is it sounds like a little sad like oh
man oh man you [ __ ] doing this like
the one time how mad we but the thing is
he understands the cow mad was he he
he's like why would you fight her let's
just postpone it we all right this is
and it like I said it worked out better
I mean you'll see 214 it's the biggest
card of the year can't wait so excited
it's cool be part of all these big cars
man I love it you're always bigger
always part of the kind of the big cards
I don't love it I love it man so I feel
appreciated well I mean no but the thing
is you appreciate but you burned it
right time I take so much drives me nuts
about you and I said this on my show and
Rogen's can tell you this sure go ahead
that's it we're open here and the
fighter in the cowboy shell that's right
fighting the cowboy new show Bryan
Callen died in Montreal guys this just
in he died so sorry Brian
tell me again all the proceeds anyways I
feel you go on these crazy runs and
because you're cowboy and the UFC brass
knows it like that Mazel Tov fight
sure I can hated that for you sure
because with Matt Brown like you guys
use a fight grade we all know the
highlight where you [ __ ] geek dudes
in the face win game over
like you should arrested because you're
set up for a title shot sure but because
you're [ __ ] Talan you have to play
that role you go oh here's another one
Denver here's Maserati oh well no no way
if I'm your man terminal yeah I know you
let's take it no Tyler nothing we had a
[ __ ] Tyler nothing but you you got to
play the Cowboys so you take the fight
and then you lose that one fight where
you should have beat him and then now
you know granted you're fighting rival
on the biggest card but you should be
you should be world champion and bothers
me you're not world champion yet because
in the reason why you're not world
champion because you rush into these
fights because you like to fight all the
time love it down I know you do but you
know what you know what you love to
check being a world champion yeah
good be fair enough you know I'm saying
that's like when I see those guys on
naked yog over here will beat Robbie
come we want that done it'll get it yes
weird your mother's BAM boom what's up
[ __ ] fighter in the cowboy show
coming alive dropping knowledge just a
million people heard that not a bit to
you I guess media thing you do all week
I said you're welcome here look you're
welcome
cuz that at 70 let's see I seventy got
yet Maya Woodley you tell me they'll
match up great with either guy sure you
have a pick in that fight don't care
right no difference to me
whatever one I think Maya might be
Woodley though that's what I said I
could see it happening so yeah feel like
you would light my light and resilience
oh my god is that we're here to say just
do you think you know what about you
typically here do is defend the singling
oh poor but the defendant single leg the
clinch
right like the Clinton Gilliam a scene
with his jujitsu sure and then you know
you just can't have you can't him on
your back like you're goddamn Brazilian
quality well back back little backpack
oh yeah I'm surprised that copy I heard
him drink I just Gege no one here wins
two month I went allow you on the
shoulder empty Cup okay so you don't
care obviously but you think Mike can
get it done huh yeah bring that card up
from the
chin I like to get Kylie's pics on these
sure yeah this is the thing get that
let's get down oh god the betting odds
now oh I hate I hate when people show me
on some fights
it's very naughty hey this is the plan
you [ __ ] Merc robbie lawler we get on
the mic we asked for a title shot and
I'm gonna go on a huge campaign for you
so I'll go on a campaign is welcome to
make it happen make it yo tell so I'm
asking Dana for though I mean everyone
has asked for something always ask them
and say hey Dana black Lamborghini
Murcielago or worse b12
don't show up with the v10 don't
[ __ ] yeah the doors that open like a
regular car I need to back the desert
yeah son I feel like you'd look good in
that thing cata have you ever won you
have driven one I tell you right now I
sat in one I just bought a new car and I
sat in one of those I did not fit and I
hurt my feelings
yeah but you make it work but I look
like wreckit-ralph and out of that I
mean like in like the manky the guy goes
I don't think is the one for you I don't
know well no well no it's [ __ ] not
this is a childhood dream of mine it's
not [ __ ] happening so give me a
second I and I'm coming to the ranch
full trip oh you were off taking that
car and it's gonna sit outside like a
model
leg macaque didn't vote this unprotected
now you can't get a Lambo and then treat
it like a goddamn fish you're gonna oh
my god I can't hate if Lamborghini if
your listeners do not give table' like
I'm doing I can't have you treat the
Lambo like that man why I own it doesn't
only be hahaha
you should get another one again no tell
Dana give you another one I'm surprised
you haven't got a car from them or you
got a motorcycle Melanie higgles
you know thanks Harley
thanks Carly [ __ ] let's get this
Lamborghini sponsorship going I don't
know if they spun to anyone Royals Royce
I gave Conor ride though I think that
you know this is a notorious edition
sheriff but you'll get there yeah they
need a cowboy audition which screams
cowboy more in the Lambo it's just a
weird collab but I mean American Muscle
cowboy Italian leather light he put a
pair of bull horns on the front alright
babe like that like that's not help
your taste in my man yeah this what the
[ __ ] cart is so stacked yes yeah I'd
love you place I gave my picks yesterday
I'd love to get your pick tonight let's
go Jones Maya Oh
you can't just rush through house Jones
Lisa house what we're doing we are we
are : I understand I yeah so Bob hold up
so how does Jones beat DC same as last
time
yeah my embarrassing ass women really
yeah well last time was embarrassing but
it's I think I think he's gonna elbow on
you thing just merge them yeah decision
I think you finished the finishing to
him yeah to me like it's that fight so
interesting because with John here's the
problem you ask me all fighting I'm the
worst person to ask about fighting
because I don't follow fighting you know
fighting though okay I hope to hear you
I know mike gilliam a very high IQ in
fighting okay you know [ __ ] fighting
and then two guys hopefully you're
fighting the winner next Woodley Maya
you said you like my like my I think
it's his back yeah I think it's his back
but what I think should happen is would
lose and get frustrating Woodley might
even try and shoot on Maya and getting a
weird scrambled eggs a cow
the thing about Woodley in this fight is
Woodley people realize will be short
like he's a hairy 470 yeah like he looks
jacked and he's definitely Jack he's a
smaller 70-david Myers a big boy he's a
big wuss 585 cops he did work all right
Cowboys farted in the studio he also did
work against Chael Sonnen is a bigger
guy
it's a my as a huge underdog there and
then cyborg versa Avenger I said work I
said if every year taming ruju bazookas
I would still pick cyborgs she's huge
we've seen in lobby yesterday I was like
god the problem with her is if if you
ever had a bar and you started talking
[ __ ] to her boyfriend she stepped in
front of you you have to just [ __ ] that
[ __ ] up you have to do have to double
up your boots you'd have to just I mean
not on the saying that beatin girls is
okay but you couldn't just get beat by
her you'd have to just get Ike out and
and bitin it anyone's gonna have a
handful though God like people like if
you don't like I guess as I borrow my
girl and take a deeper all right here we
go
let's get your mind right gotta get your
mind right there's money like I'd have
my hands full
yeah like my boys like goddamn bro
Heidi's a beast my far the best female
fighter on the planet that's not a fight
she's a big estate I think she's like a
- 1602 some [ __ ] like that
which rightfully so so they got a
picture of her and a shadow of the other
girl yeah weird this is my problem can
we not just skip it how easy is it to
get a picture of them yeah I can see
gram pressure boom damn do a selfie Asha
giver the next one that's a Cerrone and
Robbie why so wide in that picture you
are never that way so why did they do
that I see you notice I got me an off
season of the lake not really you're
always I've never seen you that way wait
see how badass that Mohawk looks sweet
right that's not a mohawk that's just
the way my hair grows that is some
straight-up people are like man gallery
sweet mug no no that's just me going
bald on both sides laughter Steve hair
like you my brother both have that
mohawk the natural mohawk just two vets
doing the damn I can't wait man to be so
fun so fun I can't believe you guys have
never met before
cuz you both so you know you both bet
never wrong and said you get it at 55
but still mmhmm yeah it's amazing
excitement
awesome I love the new weight class I
had to cut weight I'm not in a
concentration camp right now so it's
good this fight to like top seed you
guys both respect each other's not a lot
of [ __ ] talking going on no not at all
no I haven't said anything me laughs you
guys both respect each other here's like
Maine Road Dogg Pat Miletich it came out
and said he doesn't like if he was
managing Robbie Lawler she would have
had Robbie take this flight together
yeah he doesn't like this flight for
Robbie yeah I'm a bad [ __ ] you
are a bad [ __ ] you are a bad
[ __ ]
and um I'm excited yeah this week I'll
[ __ ] tune in by the pay-per-view or
watch the short clip on Instagram
everyone no man no because like the
ratings of it's just not you see it's
Bellator it's boxing HBO Showtime
because of the Conor and Mayweather kind
of stealing all the the views every show
has been down this one's such a stat
card if this suffers from kind of the
light OH
John Jones when they added me to this
card I'll take a $50,000 you're welcome
you're welcome yeah yeah thanks John
no I agree hundred percent no you're
you're let me look in the card you're by
far the biggest fan favorite on this on
this card I like it
like it why don't you think people
gravitate towards DC why isn't he a
bigger star you don't say like it it's
almost a Tim Sylvia thing like Merle Tim
Sylvia I can't sitting here I can't ask
me speak honestly is rocking that did
you get a lot of trouble trouble wet
with oh you just burnt your leg and got
AIDS and you seem just fine you know
that was like personal trouble this is I
start talking still and I getting
[ __ ] Dana calls me like you can't say
that [ __ ] well it can't be really can't
be Khaled the reason why you're a big
star I'm not trying to get in trouble
but I have no idea what you're gonna say
but yeah but also with DC I was just
saying I think it's because do you think
we get older and we cross our legs I
used to remember sitting like I don't
either and we used to make fun of my dad
and now and now I see like this all the
time and I all the time right it is so
comfortable I have no idea I know that
you're doing in there night and even
though on your knees if I have those
boots I'll do it all the time I don't
understand either I just decide roll
these day and here we are
he will make fun right dude please stop
sitting like that to all those people I
say [ __ ] you when you got these Gucci
these shoes on us what you got daughter
are you a right or left kind of right
over left I do the same thing every time
and I saw my dad sit like this like 10
years I've made fun of them make fun of
them like well [ __ ] like that now Here I
am look at us but you're still not
getting out of that why don't you like
DC together I just don't like him really
yeah I just I just don't like him is it
his fighting styles cuz he looks just
his whole overall persona see the doctor
how people feel about him what is it
though he's a winner he was a
heavyweight champion Strikeforce he
comes to the UFC he only lost to John
Jones
he beats Gustin mercs dancing Johnson
twice every Anthony retired
I like Anthony I like Anthony to also be
good for him but I'll hunk about a
silverback gorilla he is massive is me
sick dude - I found out a NASCAR before
his last fight humongous monster are you
that big how do you make 70
monster 70 was a human place I don't
think he actually ever made seven you'd
be like 74 like my badness go up to 90
and do you feel like god damn it it's
still those were those that was the Wild
West days but do you think yeah do you
think but I was saying with DC this is
why I think a lot P of issues with them
is because when he became champ John was
doing his wild [ __ ] and he never really
beat John come champ yeah and then
there's that [ __ ] talking and then on
top of that we fight Anderson Silva and
fought safe which I understand from a
business point but you're not doing any
fans in fight City intention
super-special that's what got me in so
much trouble of that exact fight really
yeah I was hungover then I did it like a
radio not of me and uh CM Punk did like
a thing at 8:00 in the morning or
something after a long night in Vegas
and someone asked about the fight I told
what I thought it was a bad fight well I
just like you said why would it really
fought save you didn't you didn't go out
there to win you just long with that
well I why would you get critiqued up
that everyone knows that if US DC I'm
sure you'd say yeah I'd say vive took
the guy that one day noticed it's
Anderson Silva when the great strides
well plan with [ __ ] you when we do yeah
a shitload once you go down there to
fight you [ __ ] go Danny and that's
why it's Donald Cerrone tell be and
that's why you're saying favorite and
that's why I think people would eat with
DC like ah
[ __ ] man because you see to hundreds of
[ __ ] sure I want you to knock a little
out in getting yeah yeah now I get that
I get that but I think that's one of the
reasons why I but this this this
demonsaw least DC's not fake okay you
know I'm saying leastly sees he's all
you're saying i john snake ah yes yes
yes he's getting a little darker now
which I like I like just embrace that
Dwight I that's what I say man I tell a
longtime just just say you're wild yeah
yeah I beat you on cocaine and what she
did he sounds he goes John there he goes
DC I beat you after doing shitload of
cocaine I was hungover I still beat you
what do you think I'm doing I'm sober
right well well then but I'm like I
don't get sober we don't fan to go bump
yeah he'll bump like if they go dude I
don't want the [ __ ] happened John was
out to tune more last night he's with
hookers he's still quoting the Bible but
he was slapping hookers doing all this
[ __ ] and he has a fight tomorrow I go on
my [ __ ] ready like I want to hear
that if I'm betting on the man it's not
saying yeah I'm with you are you betting
are you violent ah my my boy my best
friend one of those friends is a huge
better so I kind of I do it through him
payback okay yeah I get from what I
think's gonna happen
despite stuff though despite stuff for
me to pick because he's on the straight
and narrow now
yes that's what do I don't know maybe
he's not so much maybe just there
well my inside sources tell me he's not
a straight narrow but when I say it when
I see him dressed like a social study
teacher it bothers me you know I'm
saying I saw him in a polo he had the
scarf like over maybe I tease you know
maybe just maybe a stylist stylist for
that day maybe not let us change it what
if I told you that I'd say I'm gonna
wager a lot of money on ahead but with
John I listen people it's just it's
almost the Floyd Mayweather singer
Adrien Broner thing people want to see
him lose so they tune in people love
them because they want to see him win
they're gonna tune in like what you want
with DC it's kind of like it's just down
the middle like he's not fake he's real
and people for whatever reason people
just don't gravitate towards it man I
know it's tough tell you same thing with
like why isn't Luke Rockhold a huge star
he looks like goddamn GQ model how do
you Lea's love you need right muhfucka
makes you and I look like turds with
eyes let's not get you may be me but cuz
that's Luke Rockhold was here right now
our semi with even see us
oh she she would not even you and I
would just we kind of just blend into
the wall
she heard Lewis make a lot am i doing
modeling now yeah yeah I mean he's just
he's a straight there you go I'm getting
let me ask you something tell me good I
have it have any model offers from
Versace or [ __ ] Dior no me neither
no yes I have okay there you go that
solves that you know I look like [ __ ]
next to him they don't they don't call
me from modeling
I feel like Wranglers should come after
you just are Dwyer calls me for drinking
well why does it why does it rank was
call you just shirtless cowboy hat jeans
billboard sunset right Hollywood just
don't know if I like a diva
really no they show you that muddy
you're gonna do it yeah there's not much
I wouldn't do for money you're right but
yeah with with Rockhold I can't I don't
get why he's not you know our grantees
coming off a loss he's fighting now he's
fighting David branches back does the
modeling looks good
has the skills why isn't he [ __ ]
economy Gregor ish you know I'm saying
or wives Mia Donald Cerrone why did he
have the fanbase of adults around I
don't know what do you got to do I think
he just got I just live true all the
time so I know I am Who I am you don't
know what yeah well that's thing with
you it's not like you said before like
we're out on a Holograms like what the
[ __ ] you riding your Holly before a
fight like yeah like I'll Saturday I
understand that how do people shut their
life down it makes no sense to me
yeah I'm gonna wakeboard yeah I'm a
skydive would do everything but you
haven't always been like that right like
you I think he's just like I think you
found your groove later right and you
want that big run and kind of found your
group legs just before you would go more
of the typical fighter last trying and
just try to look anybody yeah no wasn't
me was not me at all but [ __ ] I don't
know are you and you have so many fights
on your belt I still as nervous as you
used to be like yeah every time still
nervous still nervous tell them it knows
what never goes away I never never faint
scared to death every time you want only
few guys who admits that sure I said
that I said I every time I was [ __ ]
terrified to fight scare to death like
I'm Andrea I'm gonna be a wreck
Oh wreck and tell us until we get in
there it's time to go that's the last I
terrified you fight another world-class
fighter in a cage it's normal it's also
a sign of intelligence if you're scared
I've had fighters like the Diaz brothers
good then shop shouldn't be fighting
fees that [ __ ] scared I guess man I
guess yeah but I mean the fear is what
keeps you alive it's like an instinctual
thing to keep you alert and aware like
imagine walking down a dark scary alley
you're like her but it'd be food and and
someone jumps out you're not ready but
if you're like alert and you're nervous
you're not a [ __ ] nonces rosetta is
ready to go some night guy already got
your serial killer yeah or or ignorance
is bliss you're just a dumbass but you
don't know what you're about to sign up
for how is anyone right you speaking
serial killers and people are scarce
so you know we're walking down this dark
alley and the crazy guys hiding in the
bushes are hiding behind the dumpster
ready to jump out and kill us okay are
they scared that somebody's hiding
ready to kill them no no they don't know
they don't even think about that they're
sociopaths don't you think about that I
always wondered like I wonder if the guy
getting ready to scare you is worried
he's someone else can do it too yeah
well the serial killers are so out of
tune with reality they think you know
like there's the only bad ones on this
earth huh but also let's say whatever
reason you went full serial killer mode
it'd be a real problem because those
serial killers are usually giant [ __ ]
with no fight back I know grab some
experience so if you got like a fighter
who want to be serie killer then you got
a pro how's wished it and that should
never happen to me ever I wish sometimes
when I'm walking down an alley I would
just get jump right guys yeah we really
always look like [ __ ] would well
you can't dress like that expect to get
jumped now put some lipstick on a wig
and some high heels and there you go it
happened now you know Kristen Becca's
know Kristen Beck was a former Navy SEAL
turns transgender so think of an eight
life she's you know she she you're
talking about him as a she well that
will chief that she's Kristen back now
so now she went from so think of Caitlyn
Jenner but from Caitlyn jealous Caitlyn
Jenner went from a Navy SEAL badass that
great badass to transgender super badass
so she shan't transgender now we've had
her on the show she said she was walking
San Diego and some boys tried jumping
her enjoy that fellas enjoy she enjoy
that I don't see the wig the high-heeled
on the lipstick you getting [ __ ] up he
like doesn't kill you
yeah huh yeah you know her that huh now
I never heard of that so that's why I
like I'm sure some the current events
we'll get to it after this but when
Trump banned all transgenders from
military she's IQ she's all over right
now because she's a former Navy SEAL
yeah just not think about that think
about that and she said when she came
out she was on a boat and she used to go
on this boat and she was still I forget
what she was when she was a man they've
seen she that's a Cheers son was like
did sort of choice I can't refer to her
he now cut the bag off I don't know if
it's there and
other women telling he maybe listen
listen if connection if I'm section
appear I'm section an animal and it's
got a dick it's a male
well you sexy animals no yeah I got
another so I mean section like town boy
or girl you know I hear you I hear you
but worth amazing if some aliens came
down and they're like you know quatre
males over there females over there yeah
my little white girl but it's got a
dingdong so we're gonna put it over
there with males yeah I get that it's
more complicated than that the hell how
is it more complicated because there's
some people in this world who they might
look like a male but they have the
wiring of a female it's not their choice
well I'm don't want to [ __ ] deal with
it gigantic ant can't comprehend and
wrap around that I need to show you this
show called I am jazz on TLC it's a girl
who since she was four
she's born a boy since she was four told
her mom like mom I'm not a boy I'm a
girl moms like shut the [ __ ] up would
like put her in timeout force her to
wear like boy clothes since she was four
now she's going through the transition
and she's a female now nicknamed jazz
you know she was born a female male she
was born a male went through when they
stopped up the puberty so now she takes
female hormones and so she science
science and the [ __ ] at will you have to
just the wirings my stuff so there's a
there's some people out there not all
but there's some transgender who the
wiring is of a woman but they're born a
boy that's crazy right dude I'm not
buying this I don't buy no goddamn
American you know yeah I don't buy it I
don't buy it
you're like Trump you like Trump George
America great again or [ __ ] it up or
[ __ ] it up it depends
it's just tough man because I think
there's some cases where you know people
just go through experiences and like now
I'm a boy but then some people are
actually born with the wrong wiring and
cowboys not buying it I just - god
dammit mom you're saying if you got a
dick you know dude like Jeff is eclis
shakily physically cowboy you'd be
correct but that's just not the way the
world were like I understand maybe in
their mind they want to be a girl know
that you are
they are in their mind that's the wiring
tap away your [ __ ] you're just too
goddamn it
listen you can't because just because
tomorrow you come in here and you want
to be a girl
you talking like me but I was like
cowboy not Romania's Brenda now like I
can't do that Brenda yeah no I'll be
like you have balls hanging between your
legs but what if I chop them off yes yes
that's you doing that you're still a man
you still have testosterone well what if
I take all the but now you're science in
it
well [ __ ] man science in it so I've got
this is oh this is a weird rathole to go
down it is I mean it's just because we
have so much like free will right that
we can do whatever we want but if we're
like if you look at this as like species
yeah like an iguana can't this is like
not I feel like being a girl yeah that's
awesome iguana though you know like
we're humans but so the other thing is
we're humans not iguana so iguanas do
nothing but sit on rocks and lay in the
Sun so it's an iguana out here what they
want to do right but I this is this is
my take on I think some people are born
like that some people go have horrible
childhoods and then something their
brain chemistry is immense everybody has
a horrible childhood
do they mine was [ __ ] awesome well I
feel like everybody wasn't horrible was
it horrible town wasn't horrible but I
feel like just a cool thing to say I
feel like is a fight I have to say that
all right on bro my dad was terrible
he's always around taking cool place
catches me inviting me all sorts of
super soakers in [ __ ] I did you want to
play catch with me all i want to do is
play a doll yeah I feel like I have to
like especially with comics I hear you
bro well back there and my mom saw - she
loved - it is annoying as [ __ ]
yeah I do drugs - never done my life I
don't - it's just be good job I've never
really done any drugs either I never
does though I don't have a device just
your drugs would be adrenaline
adrenaline yeah that's a serious drug
and the the only actual drug of ever
dealt with DMT oh how is it is amazing
did you
come on buddy Mikey I think Mike you
were doing D and he drew a place in
Austin it is a little spot in Austin we
probably did the same spot me but I'm
probably didn't seem slightest you it
wasn't Sherman and little drums and yes
it's awesome right crazy yeah crazy
craziest losing Jennifer never was the
only who lose in general arrogance I
can't I've also felt like I was in a
safe space is all good you see some
crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah what was like mine
was like a gold world of like I was like
I got shot up in this like gold sea of
comfort is cool man I am I was shot do
like a rainbow of light and that blew
through the end of it into pitch
darkness and I was looking at myself
through the third person and I was
hovering and like all pitch black and
everywhere that I was injured like my
wrists and my elbows and my knees and my
brain was like burning white light like
I was just hovering that be the plot of
get out that's what you saw if you think
that moving that's what just happened to
do that would be the plan would get out
so and then the second time I remember
hitting a pipe and I fell over sideways
and then I sat back up because you're
totally coherent like you know what's
going on you can hear people laughing
right here people laughing we did a
little like and but the entire trip I
was looking sideways and I seen a
keyhole with colors on the other side of
cleanable and on my side of it all so I
was trying to get to the keyhole was
waves of black and gray rainbows and I
couldn't tell you what the [ __ ] a black
and gray rainbow looks like I death you
know that's the death son so to think
two ways out I saw man that's a mouse in
Wonderland [ __ ] right as wow this goes
in crazy [ __ ] to Mikey
crazy right did you and not to get off
DMT but there's some crazy [ __ ] also
pretty safe but Ewan dude you and Mike
you've been together for ever it makes
it every one of my fights yeah we were
so yeah I mean everyone talks about God
El Bierzo crazy violent man we used to
kickbox it calls on a Wednesday tells
that he does need a pan to fight on
Saturday we just leave work go as soon
as we land in Japan we'd go to Roppongi
get [ __ ] wasted out of our minds and
then fight hungover so it's not like we
mike you would do this yeah every
whoever country we went to then being
line this up boogie boogie
right but you would line it on an old
school yeah I mean so we fight all over
the world we just go I used to kick
walks and do that just something to do a
lot how old were you then we're in our
2021 that's man and then that's come
such a business and such a business I
mean back then I was working
construction I mean I was my job on mid
20s and then now it's become almost like
obviously as the sport gets bigger it's
more serious more mainstream I feel like
they're now more so than ever there's so
much more of a business aspect to it and
even because I feel like Connors taking
it to another level security fighters
like Khan see trying to get shine now
and the during this TV show they're
doing this interview
woodleigh's doing press the week of
before the fight like he's in New York
Tim predator working for the FC which is
[ __ ] not not not to me I don't like
seeing that I just feel like the people
I want do the Connor sting now how much
money he's making so now I'm going to do
all these interviews everybody went back
in the day your wants money but still
back in the day like you said it was
just about fighting like you could go
like imagine imagine if on Friday if you
get first of all get blasted all over
social media at a bar right now Cowboys
hammered a hug wiser here at Crab Shack
you're Mikey yeah like that you're
[ __ ]
I assumed that you'd be so [ __ ] you'd
lose all respect but then I go in there
[ __ ] dance and be alright
you'd probably be the biggest star in
the official okay I don't dance just
Merkel I want to know what you thought
would do I've readied ever get in
trouble you saw it but I mean it used to
be we'd spent we'd come in late ish we
go into our way and so like we used to
get off the plane and we have to kind of
wait out just fight back in the day and
wait oh yeah we get their way in and a
lot of times I when you fight overseas
especially back in the day they'd
already weighed in we get bambor like
what the [ __ ] you mean everyone's
already weighed in and then we get there
and stand on scale and I look at like
all right you're good that would be that
yeah Americans aren't giving me favor no
so we cut the way then we'd usually go
straight to the bar and you spend the
whole day Saturday trying to drink
Gatorade in water and just level
yourself back Jesus Christ did it help
with the nerves doing that phone oh hell
no no getting drunk like did you and I
say we're lucky to like and they will
should go rest and think about the
fighter no we got to go in some good
food and not get hammered no we're
thinking where where can we go after we
are right now to secure getting [ __ ]
for the night then you're in Japan
wherever we were all over the world yeah
New York Japan Morocco Africa I mean you
name it we Bend and you mean mess with
them uh calm caged rats in Africa yeah
yeah it was uh Morocco is definitely a
wild [ __ ] place and then you'd be
walking around and everyone they just
ring a bell everyone put the carpet and
start [ __ ] praying and we just like
steppin over people walking around what
the [ __ ] is going on Jesus Christ so you
would fight you do that and then I feel
like when I think of after have you ever
seen what's that movie Nicolas Cage they
literally would throw [ __ ] buckets out
of their windows I go onto the street
like oh my god that's how you guys do
sewer here okay what's wild bro
aren't you worried about catching like I
don't know oh you're bola virus missile
these girls out there that was one place
I didn't mess with the girls oh you did
it I don't think they're allowed to talk
to us we were under like most place we
went we were with like military like we
were so I was with Mike seal from
Jackson's yeah oh yeah I still fought
main event there and after his fight you
got spinning kick in the balls so it was
a no contest
oh they call fight oh all the whole
crowd rushes the cage crawls in I'm
sitting there the pair of scissor
[ __ ] swiped on I swear to god I'll
[ __ ] cut you [ __ ] like
defending people to you people then you
had to come with like the armed guards
get the hell out of there damn straight
the airport gone you know [ __ ] that now
what you do are doing Saturday like it's
all good man yeah it's all good Jesus
Craig at least to stay weeks to go every
winter we'd stay for a couple of days
after and just spend every dime we made
fighting how much you make what 200 300
bucks maybe yeah what we make it Mikey
maybe some nice $1,200 you got paid
twelve hundred bucks
mm awesome now is like a stew especially
back then yeah and you don't have any in
Japan these to pay you with brand new
hundred our bills like there's like come
like in these that wax dip and they'd
like tear of the watch 101 yeah brand
new all you cuza paid money
Yakuza yes some crazy [ __ ] you hear a
lot of people like in Pride Japan days
where they just and Pam you can just
like what do you do
no you just I never got not paid really
either had any issues with it no we were
getting paid twelve hundred bucks so
they could that was probably changed
yeah if you had some crazy freaking
stories being fought all I forget how
long you've been fighting fifteen years
now
how's it only good I feel like it hasn't
been lower than 15 and though order my
34 now you got about twenty nine
nineteen when I started I was a late
bloomer but yeah some people say that's
late it's just hilarious but I've been
talking a lot of boxes that you like my
boy Pauly these other guys like 205 by
name yeah Mikey crises like you know I
started late I was 14 them oh god 14
remember C so remember when we were 14
and 15 and people would use those terms
like he's a Golden Glove boxer like oh
[ __ ]
what other oh [ __ ] don't mess with
Brandon he said yes because you better
watch the boys a black belt he's a black
belt in [ __ ] jail or whatever yeah
you're like oh [ __ ] he's black but that
was like a night at school I don't know
he's a black belt I know man and now
you're like oh he's black Don Frye oh
yeah like does it mean I [ __ ] on [ __ ]
that's Jilla you say black boys like
want a drink you say Lord this is Wonder
Boy booking for you yeah I would love to
see that match oh he's such a good guy
to you awesome and awesome he's a great
guy he started with us in Denver because
George brought him up to a Tristar
because where's that Jackson's Tristar
grudge remember fight team so it's kind
of like that triangle and then George
brought him up I forget who George was
fighting what do you want like a
high-level striker so he brought one to
boy and he was 74 no kickboxer right and
then I remember was like we're Schad
myself our boy Cody
Shane Carwin Nate Marquardt
and GSP and we're in there and no one
knew who wonderful I was in George
lights he's very good he's very good
watch out be careful and we get in there
and it was like a Chinese that was very
tiny that was I might hold I smell so
bad I had very Chinese sounds very
involved oh oh oh my car is Oh be
careful everybody says you're GSP time I
just went Asian apparently my juicy is
Asian can't wait
it but I remember when Wonder Boy got in
there yeah and we couldn't grab it can
only strike with him and he just [ __ ]
everybody eyebrow napped around right it
was like that movie Russia you remember
Chris targets in the face which one you
heal we only [ __ ] hit me I was like
that with him and then homeboy just
learned some wrestling I was doing the
dancing you ain't talented kid man super
talented a big great foot I can't wait
shine them up oh we can't do it next
because we have a plan yeah muster name
your telephone that's the [ __ ] plan
who's your manager who's your [ __ ]
manager Josh Jones Josh Jones with
Budweiser
okay I'm Angela oh that's right you're
you're a different level could you get
those boys from my NASCAR right yeah I
don't have any contacts towards him but
I'll get ahold of them I'm probably hear
a variety listen if you listen ask your
listeners talk to me talk to let's call
you
well let's connect because I get some
ideas Kelly has fight for title I swear
to God if people come on a turnaround
fight like like two weeks
hey these flight and [ __ ] the $1 ball
what real quick again I'm gonna slap the
[ __ ] out of your manager if you don't
become world champion this year you know
hail so we do some creative engine sure
what do you got brother the first one
you guys already talked about a little
bit Donald Trump tweeted that
transgender people will be banned from
the military or even entering and even
injuring can't even get in yeah
his reasons are interesting he's saying
cuz the cost to keep him in the military
little bills yeah why don't let it go
through his generals and his military
experts and see your tremendous medical
cost of disruption that is transgender
bring in the military disruption well
you ought stalking tell my name here a
girl or boy or you're I think he's a
girl
yeah or vice versa and you can put a
little dot in someone's head and
DoubleTap them what one hurts who cares
that's what I'm saying
you're good you're glad here who gives a
flying [ __ ] if I'm if I'm in Morocco
Africa and [ __ ] went down and they send
in 12 transgender to get me did you care
no not at all no it's just if they want
to sign up and defend our country this
is with what L saw that's a whole nother
thing I think this is the end of the
road for him by doing this but the other
thing is remember
he's trying getting off this edit the
lgbtq what our communities like don't
worry I'm the fight for your rights
it matters to me then um I forget things
like everyone's band live like that out
of hair yeah either get out I'm in a
[ __ ] you're helping build the wall
number booting yo yeah it's crazy it's
crazy from do you think they're going to
build a wall around New Mexico Newt just
new and you have to only fight New
Mexico yeah you think you stop can think
that when they go Mexico they're gonna
come up around New Mexico we'll see on
the budget thank you to the LGBTQ
community I will fight for you while
Hilary brings in more people that will
threaten your freedoms and belief that
was June 14 2016 god that's [ __ ]
crazy men and your girl
Kristin Beck she just said yeah let's me
facing facing you tell me I'm not worthy
emoji feel that's him that's her that's
her brother
that's her so make her drive down that
[ __ ] ranch and slit your throat well
listen Christian back you wanna come to
my house and let us say calm Elaine so
you won't come over and say yeah you
guys actually get along yeah you yeah I
promise you guys we get along I'm sure
we we were at a Brian I went to took her
to do stuff for lunch and she's sitting
there and she's just like scanning the
room and Brian's I do so
does he speak with a male's voice you
know how it goes right
just nice main on them her her you
talking about like a jack raid maybe
feeling like one of the baddest so did
he get faking boobs I think so I think
so you're gonna have to ask her
you'd have to ask her damn how about the
net slide in between does he have a dick
still again that's some information you
might have to ask him
I think so I'm not sure I mean it's
crazy right
you talk about a straight-up killer
killer makes [ __ ] Caitlyn Jenner look
like JLo straight-up Beast what else you
got Jim okay uh it's short it was a
Shark Week this week or last week I
wasn't watching on Sunday if some [ __ ]
is some [ __ ] you do cowboy huh so you
know that race that he spoke
Michael Phelps with a shark do you hear
about this I feel like you don't watch
TV no I don't but whose was a racist
shark shade of great white shark
well they promoted a psycho felt like Oh
Phelps rate winning great white shark a
shark would murder you you so much art
you'd be surprised at the results like
the shark beer like he beat the [ __ ] of
what I say because hi my name is he beat
on you of them okay let's back this up
alright that's not even fair that be
like you saying you're gonna race to
kangaroo but I'd be powder cocaine yeah
but how does the kangaroo or the shark
know they're in a race so this is what
they did they dragged meet behind the
boat and made the shark [ __ ] take off
for it yeah but is he
how does he's not in like full-on he's
not B's motive yeah there's not a nice
cowboy yeah I mean Phelps is slurring
for his life the shark is like oh my
just go he just look what's over here
true what they did is they got like a
great white shark ER I was a hammerhead
who chases these other sharks they show
don't like they clocked them as faster
speedlings chasing sharks he's fast as
[ __ ] but they're like he can't do that
forever short bursts like maybe
[ __ ] don't know again t if you
told the shark what the plan was you can
understand it as I say me I'll be a
cheetah until the cheesecake you got to
kill you yeah the cheese may be 150
years I'm chilling in second yeah I'm
working your ass off so that's not the
problem and I tune into this [ __ ]
spectacle because I was like Michael
Phelps was a great white it's gonna be
sick I like Michael friend the same type
of son boomer but I think that great
whites search and go race [ __ ] this
noise Andy diseases and within the same
tank side-by-side they weren't even the
same [ __ ] ocean it was a
computer-generated shark and that's why
Mike felt skin so much hate now like he
went in a like in the cages like oh cool
great white moon actually raised it was
like computer-generated great white is a
some [ __ ] yeah he's getting a lot of
hate right now huh he should have ripped
the bomb for a job getting hated to he's
been known to do that yeah what's he say
this uh for those of you who are
disappointed I'm sorry for that but I
absolutely had one of the most exciting
two weeks of my life being able to dive
with these animals
I bet is there's a vacation for you but
you told us you're gonna swim with it
yeah this one looks like they shared on
and they should have strapped me to him
and see if you get outrun the great
white
exactly what this you - how fast are you
are you man let's put the great white in
hunger mode see if he can get away see
he bows everybody wants to try to pick
on something or say something and
complain about something
I had fun racing the shark you didn't
race the shark so that's the [ __ ]
prom that's like that's like just tuned
into YouTube are saying and you guys
aren't fighting it's a
computer-generated Robbie Lawler I'd
like well yeah [ __ ] man
yeah let me they be there but the shark
doesn't even know he's in a race yes the
other problem the other husband there
what no one sat down with the show
because unless it checks out we need you
to race and you get a shitload of fish
if you get a shitload of fish and we
will probably put you in a tank the rest
of your life and you'll be miserable by
the little Discovery Channel honeydicked
everyone's like nah they racing and then
you find out it do I'm as well than
playing a video game there's a video
game shark versus a real Michael Phelps
in the ocean yeah and he had like a spin
on like a seal it listen if it did a
real great white next to a real Michael
Phelps that shark would have said [ __ ]
all this racing and ate him alive
because I'd open because the Sharks
saying and I've never raced in my life I
just eat and kill correct [ __ ] need
to race for it was alarming it he did
beat like 300 for shark so if they were
really racing yeah tell us silly that we
actually thought he's gonna race a real
shark what else you got Jim yeah moving
I'm a Michael Phelps tan though moving
on okay
so Brock Lesnar and John Jones kind of
both verbally agreed that they would
what they would actually want to fight
each other I called this one the
Canadian mother they're in a Brock and
John a fight they wanted water by each
other right if they would work there was
fight each other
Brock would want it and John said he
would want it said at first though I
think I think Brock said first I don't
know are they John and then Brock agreed
I think someone asked John and John was
like I'd beat the SH out of Brock Lesnar
and John put I would fight Jon Jones
anywhere any time right now I should be
worried about DC on Saturday night um
the II am well less than used to beat
you sada before does a say like that's
the biggest you there yeah for sure I'll
tell you what I wouldn't mind the old
Wild Wild West days like you and your
boy in Morocco and they can just juice
to the gills juice it up just the jus
yes called John Bull of dick pics
cocaine Brock Lesnar just WWE ride it
out and those two go at it for the best
man on earth and be entertaining all
John would have to do is stay away from
Brock for two and a half minutes
you better stay away though Gabe I got
silver back gets ahold of those skinny
all the way yeah he is gonna straight a
ride
kicking yeah fair enough I can see the
UFC making that fight I'm not gonna lie
to you I feel like anything sponsor
these days for ratings I had you no
longer fight for Bell or order anymore
right it's all about supervise now
superfight fame ratings that's what the
UFC I mean you know the things our times
are a little different now do you see
sold at WME it's just a different game
you'll have an event though you know or
those guys running the hell many more
it's kind of like what you know they
need ratings well I'm here to fight any
super fight they want what would be a
super fight for you I'll fight Brock
there's some crazy [ __ ] and I don't
think commission would grant what is the
legit super fight for you just be sure
absolutely just by just being in a
second that's a super fight that's what
makes listen there's no there's no name
that's the funny thing about these guys
that say they're fighters there's no
name they call me with and they're like
um say the name I'm like oh yeah yeah
I'm not really that and now what if they
called you like I tell boy um you were
CM Punk all they have to do is call me
and say cowboy you're fighting July 29th
I say okay there's very few guys like
thank you Jim Miller you know who never
mattered to me which is always needed to
win that's all I needed was a date I
didn't care about it who seen uh yeah I
agree and that's why your towel boy well
it bothers me as they know that and when
you should be fighting for titles they
[ __ ] know you can take the fight and
you take it yeah so I need a middle man
anyway no man do but fighters say that
I'll fight anyone anytime and my man
John Lee say this guy's name I think
I've told the story before I forget what
show but then maybe I have it big guy
who is fighting on
I'm not gonna save me I'll tell you out
there with the same manager and he goes
brother you won't see why my job so cool
you want to see why it's so cool watch
this
I just got dis light for this guy to
hear this afterwards he was biggest by
his life watch this
puts on speakers funniest watch this is
why my jobs are cool the guy picks up
yours what's up man
it was guess what you got the fight I
was telling you about
bla bla bla six weeks radio silent yes
guy goes ah [ __ ] well I guess I'll take
it
let's get this chatter hangs up the
phone among years old I thought doesn't
no deficit sounds like homeboys about to
get murdered terrible fight for him by
the way as well well that's the thing we
were what I mean Talk's cheap when
you're like I'll fight anyone [ __ ] you
and then they call you in the Loess on
the other side they're like oh [ __ ] four
more weeks then the time never met it
never mattered I never had him call me
with opponent I'm like oooh or my team
said like oh yeah super fight for you
would be a mean father everyone but GSP
I love it
second Conner sure Conner up 55 I'll see
71 makes much sense one of my senior
Nate Diaz glad to share I'm Nick Diaz
any of the all of it I mean a bit does
it I feel like you'll have issues really
one either but usually you just want to
fight them you don't really have issues
with down no no issues just it's go fund
me I love it there's that feeling is
unbelievable when you're in that cage
man you can't yeah I mean you've done it
as you know oh yeah you know what it's
game forwards to a man and there's all
the people that sit at home they think
they could tell you what you should be
doing and shouldn't be doing they have
no idea what what it's like out there no
it's nuts nuts it's like a craziest
tunnel vision [ __ ] Wow to [ __ ] ever
there's also no way to kind of get in
that boat I can go through all the
training camp you want you jump out of
planes you can ride ostriches whatever
[ __ ] you're doing but there's nothing
that can mimic like the actual fight
like the nerves walking out the cage
it's very strange
I love it very strange I mean that's why
I think I do all the crazy I do because
that's the closest things I can get to
that feeling this is
the problem with you Cowboys once you do
finally decide to retire which is what
next three years man oh no three years
from being movie star so wonder that
kitchen will suck your boy should be a
movie star at least a TV 6 so let's say
- let's say you have two years let's go
five I don't see 505 no I'm going to -
three
listen I got a lot of lot of things to
buy still you god damn it you're at
least paying taxes of course I think
just slap your manager just yeah I'm all
along I'm caught up I'm caught up but
you're not American I'm trying to yeah
there's some superfight three I'm sure
want to come your way what else you get
Jim
alright this is a getting some hate
online there's a footage of a shark
being dragged behind a boat and I'll
show you the video real quick first of
all kind of shark is it oh wow sure is
it that's a limit on our chart then and
well in the boater kind of laughing well
I call that jet ski and uh yeah because
so no one knows if it's dead or alive
but either way it's was probably dad and
they're dragging it back to this guy and
I don't think it's dead like they might
have been he's kind of move in like u
s-- attorney oh that's [ __ ] up to do
right sure like you got you hunt Mike
you look so you kill a lot of animals in
his life
yeah you guys kill some [ __ ] but this is
[ __ ] up like there has to be some sort
of standards for god sakes
like what like why would you do that so
you said nurse shark lemon shark animals
can't kill me so don't care but then
with the lemon shark you don't have
anyway if you're in the water a done
that's gonna be pretty scary really I
think not [ __ ] a lemon shark really
anyone tangled with lemon shark and you
know let's play a little game
what is that you're in a concrete room
the size of this room yeah any animal
you think you could really take awesome
you're you're and you're naked you're
buttoning because you have yeah we're
like right up animal mode of animal mode
I would I'll play this route what is the
i way got back from us to wait and the
animal that you think you could use a
[ __ ] up because i'm thinking a house cat
might [ __ ] get at you not you take
care of it a corner to clot about me
SEO I'm getting nine might scratch me
I'm slapping the [ __ ] out of it by the
tail killing it but I was in Australia
and I was with the Koala a destroyed
claws things are so slow okay sloth
destroyed kangaroo not with a big
jacked-up male one female I was feeling
that thing so we're talking 40 pound
gang room
maybe we'll have your kangaroo okay what
if I go what if I'm like that you're in
this room you can't go anywhere it's to
the death look about like that so now
let's try girls that would like teats
like a coyote your own 35 pound pitbull
I've sung I'm Dan and I'm dying now now
we've sat this pitbull down and we
talked to him he knows that he knows the
game he knows the game it's not like the
shark race you're fighting a virtual dog
it's like one of the buggers coming to
kill you like one of those Dade County
pitbulls yeah it's hot Miami in the
backyard yeah I already broke the chain
Kimbo Slice typo yeah he's [ __ ]
coming I mean probably not a [ __ ]
flight in your vlogging at your dick you
have no underwear on tight I can go very
well Mac investing a handful ok root
cause I was thinking that when I was
with them like I would [ __ ] with these
things up now now this room filled with
water and we're in fighting a lemon
shark and it's killing you it's not just
swimming around knowing you're not there
god I don't feel like the lemon shark
unless you got ahold of like my neck my
face to look in that limit or how what
is it what was it what are you gonna do
I take these old dick beaters huh I put
it right in its eye and its gills and I
rip it apart
mm give me tops don't get me wrong
Calvin it's gonna be tough you think
you'll let me start kill you
well I reckon like anything kill me I'm
gonna fight you to death but I know but
there he goes
like in the Vegas odds you probably a
plus 120 I mean you're trying to put
your little finger in his eye and it's
just zipping zinging [ __ ] biting your
leg bitin your arm took a chunk out of
your arm now your arms rendered useless
because I you just have one thumbs me
tough I'm not saying it's gonna be
you're gonna go over the Gil and you do
a little to bite your finger off now
what we're screwed I'm screwed looks
good just go to lemon strike though I
like sharks I always try it when I run
scuba diving I love to [ __ ] chase
after him out my I want laughter yeah I
want to ride a shark I want to grab his
dorsal fin Ennis and his side fin to go
for a ride you watch way too much movies
deep blue sea is over time up see that
guy's a shark Wrangler
no but that's
I always try it doesn't work like that
I'm sure doesn't work like that
I'm sure it's how that lemon shark fight
would go down you try riding a great
white
you will [ __ ] you up yeah it's not like
I messed up you bit me I won't do that
again it's game over female yeah it's an
end game i watch that [ __ ] though David
Blaine swim with great white sharks and
eat bananas underwater with them some
weird [ __ ] ate bananas straight-up ate
bananas and water why I've no idea what
else you got chin is that a lemon shark
teeth yeah let me taste you that Mike
you had a pretty serious yeah you're not
now you're not you're not [ __ ] acha
and retract what I said that's what I
call the lemon shark
oh my draw yeah your holy balls yes you
can put your finger and what Gil yeah
well move well I'm not gonna do [ __ ] I'm
not doing [ __ ]
you talk about that many great white so
what I call the lemon strike and it
looks like that holy balls
yeah looks super scary really it might
take a super fisherman all really see
fish out of date you having it
encounters with great whites or anything
Mikey nothing down in Florida there's
some bull sharks down the right tiger
sharks bull sharks
look listen man we don't we don't we
don't we don't drag them behind the boat
yeah that's so [ __ ] up I heard that
yeah I mean you guys know hunted I heard
I heard Howard Stern say the sneeze
balls deep in the animal rights of late
he said when you catch a fish you know
somebody like put him back in the water
but when the human hands like the oil
from human hands touch the fish the fish
is [ __ ] so we throw it back they're
probably gonna die anyway so you should
buy just eat it I don't believe that is
that bro science it's bro sighs uh you
know I mean Mike yeah
bass like teeth yeah teeth and leather
yeah silly Howard Stern really abstract
I might have made that up Oh what else
you got chin yeah I'm not [ __ ] let me
try tell you how much I've never been
hunting could you imagine how easy I
mean it's funny that you everyone does
in your hunting so
doublet I love it man especially birds
but could you imagine hunting humans how
easy would be be the easiest thing in
the world if you had up all you to do is
put a sign [ __ ] and pool party and
we'd be running headlong is super easy
breezy too breezy that's how a lot of
these mass shooters go down yeah
heylia's came down and hunted human did
not for me for me hunting though it's
just like such a process Ben and you're
sleeping on the rocks and all that [ __ ]
I know I'm with some straight-up gnarly
dudes and you guys love hunting but I
just can't I mean can we cut instead the
Four Seasons how's that work we bring
the RV so yeah we're glamping out there
usually yeah you guys are like you're
sleeping in good beds like you're having
good dinners and not [ __ ] in the
woods and using leaves and stuff no
those days for me never existed I would
never wipe my ass with Lemmy was
explosive diarrhea sometime I hike I had
to do that but and that sometimes that
happens a bit yeah
I'd be down to go with you guys I don't
know
come turkey hunting with this ones that
turkeys coming too you know what turkeys
can't kill me I don't wanna do it
I wanna do some dangerous [ __ ] you ever
go like grizzly bear lion give us names
of all predators I don't like killing
predators why cuz they're [ __ ]
killers themselves that's what I'm
saying I like this update it hey bro
your cowboy I'm going to up the Hamptons
here it's all about hunting turkey
yeah they hunt them with our hands well
as oh so me and my this year hunting
turkeys with hatchets yeah I mean what's
next one you'll kick penguins around
Turkey about the turkey wing go to pet
market areas if you want I'm trying to
hunt some the [ __ ] man you have a talent
like the grit I don't like how they hunt
those bears man they treat him a dog and
then they [ __ ] up so we don't have to
do that
now you're talking my just take one out
my boy came Tamron Haynes I hope you
know him good fun I don't hate song he
asked me he invited mythical bear height
bow honey with him in Alaska and I was
like yeah you don't want to do it so I
want to kill bear man the [ __ ]
predators are badass well because
they're badass because you're scared to
kill the bear like you're scared of what
now dozens no no I mean I'm I have a gun
Arabo like what chances you have if I
was switched into this room with a bear
hug looking good for know what scams
like ask
with us I'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
will be on the ground yeah I think you'd
be up in the trees while I'm down there
killin anyway it's probably better idea
that's probably better idea I said the
bear comes up your tree well not good
luck into camp first to look like as a
savage or my boy a green tree I saw him
in Australia get again another monsters
i I know the best hunters in the world
but I don't do it okay so I'll go with
him I'll be like the side piece yeah
game Kenny while you guys shoot them but
[ __ ] it turkey turkey there's a 10% gay
boys that was about 15 minutes get them
came in with the slang it's like if I'm
going on it's not gonna be Turk my first
time hunting can't be turkey why they're
just lame and also turkey tastes so
boring k so boring I'm not a turkey fan
now
hey Turkey what about pheasant or duck
hey bro I'm not killing we're not
hunting ducks oh man go right across the
war so far
grab a duck by the neck and that's not
hunting what else you got god dammit you
too
I thought you guys killed cool [ __ ] duck
hunting it's the funnest you know what I
bet it is
it's [ __ ] did you just say no idea
you know what no one gets a machine gun
why they hunt ducks but never the hunt
with me yeah not what about what if we
did like ostrich hunting with knives
well ostriches would nine or just cut to
come and it comes out for a jump on you
back cut his head off
does slit the throat I think Jim try
seeing some Cowboys [ __ ] think of that
TV show you and me hunting [ __ ]
ostriches with knives and Mikey's the
expert going fellas
those clothes are only did hey fellas
those claws get holy is to be a long
night
and when I got [ __ ] and it's like risk
factor if it did they do nine not on not
on an ostrich
you ever seen ostrich down bring up an
ostrich for me no no I'm not talking
about your [ __ ] Denver Zoo ostrich
I'm talking about some [ __ ]
Australian African ostrich
look at those [ __ ] talents cowboy oh
you make look at that one that's
yeah they don't ask photo Josh are like
a [ __ ] yeah look at those talons
click on the black feet there look at
that thing they're dinosaurs yeah you
talk about [ __ ] around playing
grab-ass with these ducks I'm talking
about getting our Swiss Army knives and
taking that thing down
Wow it's a philosoraptor it is those are
categories same [ __ ] yeah I guess we're
right on brother
look I tell you not to do it says lay
down prone this one dude on the fastest
fine dig they're huge they're huge so
what are you waiting here often what is
your approach battling an ostrich would
you think no late I mean so awesome man
so you're that guy for your stuff you're
that guy running okay here's what we do
brother here's what we do this is the
game plan you're the wild trades when
you like the adrenaline you can approach
them face on face on yeah cuz all right
you're gonna be a distraction I jump
behind them slit his throat you dig that
sure well I still want to play [ __ ]
with these ducks dunk a little cross the
stream I love it
so you're one-on-one with a one-on-one
with the ostrich whatwhat's your your
technique taking his legs out you got to
give me the ground we go ahead and grab
a whole that stupid long that yeah
[ __ ] triangle his that and I'm gonna
take these two fingers and shove them
right that's stupid snout and suffocate
him suffocate him and you come along
with the knife and wheat in austria wien
ostrich you down for that yeah that's a
lot of meat the people hunt ostrich
already I can hold up yeah they can are
down everything I heard they're good
meat to really like lean ostrich burgers
algorithm but sure happened we're we're
can you go to get an ostrich provider
some some restaurants that have them see
that's one time about Kelly you talking
about ducks geese
Canaries at Petsmart I'm talking about
ostrich burger like some wild [ __ ]
fairness and not with
I'm not trying at your heat-seeking
missile launcher to kill these things I
thought I said well you're going ahead
and why do you want you go hon a lion
different different story different way
difference to whole lines I'd only kill
lines you saw the whole Cecil the lion
share
yeah but why feels trying to kill us
like I am and I why I bear but not a
lion if you're talking predator this
lard-asses a [ __ ] lion that's right
here's the TV show with this cowboy
campaign calls up goes fellas there's
this [ __ ] lion Africa man killing the
locals we need to send you guys in you
have two weeks to prepare how do you I
would like you so they call you right
now and this is you have two weeks
prepare you are living the wrist
lifestyle eating Ho Hos and Starbucks
coffee what is it what is day one
preparation for lion killing i Skype
with campaigns okay with green tree and
I give a checklist I did they give me
the check yeah
then you and Mike and I arrange travel
and then we just go from there Amy a
[ __ ] show one was probably gonna die now
it's not gonna be me good chance it's me
yeah I have zero experience in the field
and it's my idea and I don't want to be
you know like that site I don't want be
so what do we afford we watch ghost are
darkest before we went nope we just roll
straight it'll and no preconceived
notion on so we don't wanna have any
nothing you don't be to hunting lions
what would you do if they called you in
campaigns like yo man I can't make it we
have this crazy-ass lion Rogan can't do
it either
shop I just don't to sing cuz he's a
giant Polizei let's go you say let's go
no preparation needed but yeah go by
yourself yeah I don't know well not very
good by myself but I do it I mean you
know I could later so I'd be lonely and
should have been my cell phone wouldn't
work and I know that feel bad for the
line I've seen with this cuz like you
let die [ __ ] this guy guy got him yeah
that's another one yeah I do I got him
and yeah I do it though we had a team I
mean I feel bad killing lying he's
[ __ ] badass predator but I'm just
saying he's like he's killing humans
though like he's tasted human blood yes
so as an elephant so what happened is
what happened you had to redo the story
for me what happened is your family was
out there merger drill merger girl
this lau hurt your girl now to revenge
now is a revenge story yeah we shoot a
whole documentary on it avenge you're
upset
we have therapists trying to talk to my
yelling on the violence isn't the answer
and you just refused to take their
advice yeah this badass team together
and finally meet the lion you realize
you're no different
yes the same you've come friends we have
that Hooda Hepper we have the eye-to-eye
moment right before I kill him no he's
still dying he took my family away mm to
see him and he realized he's just doing
lying [ __ ] she's doing I didn't know was
your girl he didn't never [ __ ] up
she was a somebody else's girl hahaha
let's get Jim went down such a weird tan
tada
God Nate Diaz gonna be walking out a
flame in Floyd Mayweather his team got
an 80s to walk out with him I mean
what's your own take on the Conner Floyd
stuff why why is Nate walking out with
Floyd just just walk honors honored but
how would that [ __ ] would one here's
like that's an MMA fight and also I
don't care I beat him I thought I
thought you know like what like oh cool
oh that's a boxing world man I you know
I edited on I don't understand it like I
came out with Bieber before it's the
lane rap looks like that that's that's
what Boyd's that's a comeback comeback
walk out with Nate but Floyd insane
thing right like Floyd at the press
conference you bringing up like you tap
like a little [ __ ] which is hilarious
yeah which is good material but this is
like alright I'm from stock Jeff when I
was just in London with Floyd when the
[ __ ] went down with Conor I'm gonna make
it Colin ideas I would love to see him
walk out with Floyd oh but this is this
is Floyd's like loud side piece vocal
guy he was also on the hollow pile of
and hip hop he's like dying for
attention
mmm I mean I don't we're not true then
what does that do I mean oh yeah would
that would that at all Meza like oh [ __ ]
on him you got the idea or I can't do
this anymore you say 120 million I'll
[ __ ] no man that's Nate years I'm not
coming out here but you be the last
fight I know but still it's [ __ ]
surviving and like that's your move
that's your movie advice for if I was
Connor come out with the girls that he
hit before yeah like I have all six of
them like all right your move man you
move I got here's all the girls in
violence and they're all walking me out
so but however you want to play it we
can do that yeah here's the last girls
you beat I like how strange is that like
the chair will move I don't think boys
do smartphones like he might be with
them but it's more violent only boys
ready but keep level-headed Manningham
that car getting his mind you got your
stage you're watching Oprah now hey come
on that's one source of course she did
it was not heard about it there's so
much life to be lived out that I'm out
doing other than your doing instead of
participating it might be circus should
I watch it and care what do you think
about it living opinion for Tana a good
good for Conor man right yeah [ __ ]
right on man you're gonna make all that
money [ __ ] yeah cuz you would you don't
like Floyd Mayweather for a [ __ ] yeah
100 million I would [ __ ] a man live on
TV for a million dollars so aggressive
chemical I mean I'm talking about boxing
a you know 100 million dollars I got
anything for Jesus yeah there's a you
and I you would let the new Liam pages
from the Train on you 400 million yeah
bring it on I do such a good job they'd
want to do it again who some of the some
of the remaster the trilogy well I'm
well [ __ ] you manager I don't know what
doing is not fair but I don't wanna know
jr. my bad good we're done good for good
for Conor I mean that's Kyle and is my
dizzy Stanton chance not a [ __ ]
chance we think is zero chance to fight
the number one pound for found most
offensive boxer on the planet know what
about his awkward style cowboy because
you're awkward don't mean what so what
soup would those listen I so you're
talking about football I'm sure you have
a lot of football friends and they're
fast wide receiver fast right yeah
fast fast for 440s seven four three four
three okay awesome fourth may be in for
two is for two I thought I danced Anders
sure now this phone has a fast guy in
the world on a track on his turf he's
not that fast anymore he's not that fast
first ten yards can be interesting
though
now as the race goes on yeah
he's going to pull away that first those
first few steps it's going to give him
some problem sure that's what that's
that's my argument on this Conor Floyd
fight those first few rounds gonna be
interesting okay after that once Floyd
downloads the data his movement stuff
like that then it could get out of hand
but those first few rounds of his
awkwardness his style that really helped
me as a puncher's chance absolutely for
sure I give me more even yeah you know
with your style your stance
Floyd those first couple rounds gonna be
tough man if Floyd's fighting me for a
hundred million dollars I'm going out
there and head kicking it so here's that
here's the ham head kick now they've
ruled me unruly can ever box again at
100 million I'm moving to the moon
what's that what's that head kick worth
to you about 100 million hundred million
check this out in Connors contract that
Floyd did with them if he does any MMA
moves at all spinning back this elbow
knees kicks
takedowns doesn't get paid oh wow I
still wanna do it yeah I do yeah but
that's the thing he can't do any of that
stuff otherwise it'd void split contract
yeah I'd had you think about how famous
you'd be after that not a hundred
million famous yeah you pick [ __ ] up
later
not 100 mil losing even hundred mil
hundred million so much money so much
money sponsors and salt predicated on
you not going MMA mode and kicking them
or near them something like that yeah
like that was the first shot you know
the thing about Floyd he didn't get to
where is that candy stupid that contract
is solid like you can't do this can't do
that
I think Ennis suspected some that
[ __ ] I guess for sure yeah that's
gonna do it
I'm starting my ass whipped yeah yeah
you know what that's not a horrible idea
like if you just get in lit the [ __ ] up
like 9th 10th round like [ __ ] I am
hanging dueling sorry sighs in the
moment ah man my bat knocked him out
though I've had you'd be screwed that
money it's not worth it man what else
you got you about this Chinese MMA gym
club they're adopting all these orphans
at a young age to train them in MMA and
to fight for their organization so is
that
like a sweatshop operation they have
their Horsens the little kids they have
no homes and some people so the police
are investigating it but well yes here's
the behind the scenes they're like great
idea
orphans it's raising me fighters all the
money and proceeds they make just kick
back into the school true true but
here's the thing do they want to do it
are they forcing no they know it's a
will so the kids are like there's food
here the shelter and everything else so
the problem kind of a weird yeah but
it's like is there food here their
shelter I guess we'll go fight because
we get food and shelter true but what's
the other option
ya know the kids seem to prefer to be at
the gym they're 12 years old you know
what but that's why it's a little they
make em like fight to the death or
whatever look you see these kids are
here god damn it go to melee Zack how
old are these kids 12 ish this mmm a
club with Dobson trains two orphans with
UFC fighters you mean MMA fighters yeah
is there any light I do in Conor why are
they showing Conor Diaz highlights no no
there wasn't footage online somewhere
but that is not it this little dude
feels like he loves it yeah we've
trained over 400 past 16 years that's
not that my name 16 years but yeah yeah
there is a video that's out and I will
see the promise the kids are willing to
do it and if this is their only option
if to the other options them on the
streets starving that's where it gets
tricky yeah
there's no I mean to be honest there's a
lot of kids I go like YMCA there's some
boxing programs around America YMCA in
like hey if you come here we're going to
feed you we're going to house you in
return through grass table you're going
to fight for true true true I'm saying
like they keep them off the streets like
like you don't have a home or they don't
know where to go that's true it's a
little different for some I'll have an
issue because the alternative is pretty
nasty damn boys are scrapping
yeah there's making a fight it's awesome
oh there you go on the god damned yeah
he says all
is so dark and I'm an issue with this I
wish they had other options but if this
is the only option I'm not mad at it
fair ask what else you get you how about
you guys wanna see this yes what is it
it's a crocodile dragon an entire cow
across the river in Australia ah ah damn
how about oh we got does he grab the
crotch and just dip out it just swims
with it's not even a big deal the video
but it looks pretty crazy so those
crocodiles enormous it's a giant
crocodile yeah you fellas ever have any
issues with crocodiles 20 feet low no
crocodiles or cats don't function really
yeah another some in Florida are
crocodiles
yeah alligators in Crocs I'm getting
salt waters down there - yeah I mean I
don't know I don't I don't [ __ ] with
crocodiles if you start surfing that
water weather water sport you're doing
this Crocs in that water we we've ever
[ __ ] with alligators while
wakeboarding in Florida I'm realizing a
crocodile analogous I think a crocodile
eats now again right crocodiles are the
big big problem yeah a problem that's
like the very white to a player
especially the saltwater croc you got
some issues underneath yeah now I'm dead
no you don't mess with that
oh good school video Jim what else you
got how about a dude had smuggled to
king cobras inside potato canister
potato potato chip canisters like those
like the Pringle bilinguals ones yeah
from China to here and they found it
this is I think this is a fake one here
because I heard the snakes died but uh
what was he doing with him just so he
does he collects all these like
protected species uh-huh though the the
cops actually found out they smuggled
these they let the delivery of another
thing go through follow to the house and
all these different like turtles and
reptiles that are just like endangered
so I get he's a collector that probably
sells it you know on the black market
and he's trying to get these king cobras
in an incredible box
Pringles boxes are my thing is kind of
what a sketchy terrifying flight
like a Pringle is not very secure that's
like saying the Starbucks lid you have
there yeah let me go and put a [ __ ]
baby hip on the Starbucks cup and you
just can chill a hippo fine a lake or a
Cobra
come on tinny and they're just [ __ ]
hitch it no sir not happen so he's just
playing to get these back to his house
and then I sell him down what a terrible
idea
yeah he didn't like this better tase's
terrible idea this was in California
yeah
Jesus smuggled from Hong Kong to
California yeah check in his carry-on no
it was a kid I was underneath there try
my snakes on a plane yes nice on a plane
Samuel Jackson whatever I do obviously
don't put snakes in the Pringle bus what
else get you how about this a coyote
walked up to a people in a golf cart
just to get some water
that's clearly a coyote mixed with a dog
is it yeah like a fox them yeah
cody's are like sketchy gross
Kylie's don't [ __ ] around like this
either right my hot coyote and they're
super smart and hard too hard to get
bring eggs or wicked smart right they
think that this one's injured so I also
give you that coul of people no that's
like a crock right that only look like a
cat to mangy [ __ ] coyote God the
person doing the video needs to relax
whoa this is [ __ ] nut there yeah
that's a guy no golfing yeah you're a
real [ __ ] if you do it because you
saw a coyote on a golf course
yeah that's that's like that it goes
across your time with a German Shepherd
yeah Jeremy right there
let's turn Shepherd put my helm on the
others have to mix it a shoe it makes
breed for sure relax Inside Edition
anything else chin real quick fight news
Neil Magny versus ruff how the sannyas
vision sucks my device and son are used
to train with Neil right yeah you ever
absolutely I like me a good guy like
gazelle doing the twins to 15 when is
that and missing September night all
cool
there you can go out there just as
you'll see guess we as a guest
Budweiser's doing a big impression of
their so going the ice cold refreshing
always refreshing my well well he's very
fetching about that'll be fun
that'd be good man Neil Magny dos Anjos
it's a good fight
yeah I can you on that fight go to my
cardio I can you know that's the same
card as a homegirl Shevchenko in a
million you know they rescheduled diet
for that yeah and they also have pulses
on the all day about Mighty Mouse my
mouth anymore boards you know that's a
good one should be if you want me to
guess I mean pay-per-view that's going
to do do you want me to get you the free
one right to payment it's going to be on
pay-per-view and the headline is going
else are we back are we jumping back to
the wired some people not as a mrs.
eller and Gondor dos Santos woohoo that
might help the ratings just Dos Santos
were sprinkles you know I just seen him
I'll just have the the new USC Institute
how is it there badass it'd be crazy
yeah it is we had a spa day there on
Sunday it's pretty good if I got a spa
there yeah really
yeah hot tub close point I colleges and
everything they have like a sports
masseuse kind of like a sports actor
Andrew yeah she physical therapist type
deal be cool feels like you know like a
legit massage place it being wake
overhead like happy endings I must say
yeah the girls over from rhinos right
spirit rhino they're they're like a real
retreat for the father it's like let's
real retreat yeah let's put a couple
other girls rhino
peanut get a couple girls around just
walking around in the wet area you know
and hot tub that is there with yes yeah
that is amazing as amazing yeah very
much self state-of-the-art facility its
huger huge really humongous yeah someone
kept what can you do that where the
heifer he does I'll step I'm not getting
in my into their but what do you guys do
there now you can get Danny come with me
I'm bringing in yeah I don't know man I
feel like they taint my water something
like that died but so what do you do
there like you walk in like hey welcome
you'll see training center how you
feeling today cowboy
anything we can do for you grape soda
what do they do that pretty much that
exactly why I made homeless Jackie
like there's like a wait great so that
was so random there's like a pool
there's a spa late raw wait room full
rate room
I mean who uses it but that was my
argument right I was like when I went
down thinking like man they had this
huge incision be like nobody definitely
dead it's [ __ ] packed with whom all
the COC fighters there's like everyone
was there just using this place yeah
it's actually worked out great and then
how many UFC fighters live in Vegas may
know everyone went everyone goes there
like after getting rehabbed on their
knee because all everything is paid for
by the USC so all the like specialists
are there to help you out are in the
house it's kind of house really cool and
I was like why don't you guys have dorms
here and then I remembered because
degenerates like me which stays there
forever
ever I would come in like cannot make
the spa parents just to keep my name on
the boards you know you would it will
not be pool party XS night's sleep all
day recover the cover they're not glad
they don't do it hot tub cool plunge
sweat it out massage do it again can
have that no that's why they cannot have
dorm rooms because razors so many guy
for would abuse it like you that's crazy
I figure this big open arena they're
like well and they have um Conners
working out there so this camps the
cancer so right now it's busy but I
can't imagine busy year well I just was
totally like yeah I mean while I was
there I probably seen 50 fighters
Francis Dewey who was there out of there
like he's doing his camps and he was
there I saw Eddie Alvarez was there Fran
ran into him because every three most
guys come in for three or four days you
know kind of get in and out well they
have like a nutritionist there that will
set up an entire diet for you so Brett
if you want to go in there fight week or
not immediate every week they'll cook
your meals prepare them everything ready
for you the whole time you're there
free of charge free everything's free
charge kinda cool really cool I mean
there's giant pool with a treadmill on
the bottom of it I was a big fan of it
take you hunter I think you need aqua
Sox clearly that's kind of where it was
real ruffling I really by running
outside yeah
so stupid I did your whole plunge in the
hot tub of cool sauna steam room that's
kind of cool I rode they have a tanning
bed
it's not really tanning bed is they just
laser because Sun yeah get the vitamin
dude if I'm in deep man that's
interesting I didn't I didn't think
people use that much as a ton of money
it's packed well and they had the
contender show going on said all the
contender guys right so incensed I'm
sure it goes you look like from here to
there it's hot they're hot not that's
actually a decent card Wow neo Megan
just hinges on the bottom there I'm sure
they won't be on the bottom for long now
that it turned that's it
Cowboys a busy man we gotta get you out
of here brother this man yeah I got it
supposed to be somewhere at one says
perfect timing you got what do you got
another interview yeah I got all my
Yossi [ __ ] I do
I mean what hate how you feeling for the
a/v geek how you feeling what do you
think Robbie Lawler win the match no
they need they need a just a Bolton list
on the Boer ass let me read off it what
do you want me to say no here's the
signal [ __ ] that noise what they need to
do is you should do one interview the
south cowboy feels about the fight
Robbie Lawler fight in Anaheim is career
check those off you got anything else no
we're good we're good
just should letter be a sheet of paper
but just like that they say the same
[ __ ] and how so how are you feeling for
this cam if you don't answer it right to
say so what do you end do what do what
he see what would the holes do cm Roger
on I'm glad you asked that because I'm
give away the game plan and then they
get home they're like that's weird I
can't figure out why I can't break a
hundred views on my youtube because you
asked out with the exact same questions
and it's weird and just know what
Brendan got 1 million downloads which I
guarantee this well why did they talk
about well him and Brendan talked about
killing ostriches with their bare hands
in Africa they talk about Robbie Lawler
nope well can we check that box we
checked that we checked like that well
brother you know I'll see I'm rooting
for you on Saturday I always root for
you thank you mom
it's a big one they're all big for
they're all at this time a game my
lights are all big you see 2:14 this
Saturday the man the myth the legend
Donald Cerrone will be fighting tune in
John Jones DC the rematch it doesn't get
any bigger sideboard give ones on that
[ __ ]
so dude I know you're busy you know I
love you I'm glad you came in but got it
keep killing it man Donald Cerrone
at what is it at is it a cowboy Oh My
Damn yeah cowboy Cerrone boom so long
enough it's really at the fighter in the
cowboy now that's fun in the cowboy yeah
that's all we're going to sign off if
they're out of here this is the fighter
in the cowboy we're out route